hi friends thank you so much for joining
it was so nice to see so many of you at
the rstudio conference whether in person
or virtually on the discord too
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup i'm rachel calling in
from boston today
we are streaming out to youtube live
today so if you've just joined now feel
free to say hi through the chat window
and maybe where you're calling in from
i'm so happy to have my friend tom mock
here with me today to teach us about
cordo
i know we've heard a lot about it lately
on twitter and linkedin and the rstudio
conference so i've been excited for this
welcome to cordo workshop
if this is your first time joining one
of these sessions this is a friendly and
open meetup environment for teams to
share use cases teach lessons learned
and
just meet each other and ask questions
together we're all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
i will be sure to share a link in the
chat where you can also find out about
other upcoming events too we have
meetups like this every tuesday
at noon eastern time
and also data science hangouts every
thursday at noon eastern time
this is our first two hour workshop in
this meetup environment so thank you tom
for being the first here
during the event you will be able to ask
anonymous questions as well
through our slido link which we'll share
in the chat too
and we can also try and answer these in
a follow-up blog post as well
while we want to help with as many
questions as possible
we likely won't be able to stop during
the workshop to answer as many questions
with so many people on today
but i'd recommend also asking follow-up
questions after the event on
community.rtstudio.com
curtis from our team just made a quarto
tag there as well
with all of that said thank you so much
tom for getting us all started with
cordo today
awesome thanks rachel for hosting and
for helping with getting this all off
the ground um i'm going to try screen
sharing my screen once and then we can
always flop over to the presentation if
we need to
so today is going to be a bit longer so
as rachel mentioned it'll look a little
bit different in terms of the format
that you may have been used to
we're going to cover quite a bit of
material and so a lot of this is kind of
getting people excited about porto
giving you some of the overview of what
porto provides
but i've seen two hours while that seems
like a long time we're not able to cover
everything so we're going to make this
part of a longer series and if you want
to come and join us later on we're also
going to do things like creating a
quarto blog or creating quarter
presentations or ones very specifically
focused purely on python as opposed to
today which would be mostly focused on r
with the big mix of python in it
for today's slides we're going to go to
a link and we'll share it here in the
chat real quickly but this is the
material for today
this website will be up forever so you
can always reference this material in
the future
there will be an rstudio cloud link as
well as a place where you can actually
download it locally or clone a github
repository into your local r studio
but for today if you didn't want to
install anything you just want to get
off the ground as fast as possible you
could always go into rstudio cloud
that's linked there as the third item
i'll zoom in a little bit here just so
that it's it's a little bit bigger when
we're going through
but let me know if you have any trouble
seeing it in in the comments
so to orient you on this slide or kind
of this website uh if you go to the left
it says workshop intro to quarto and
authoring quarto the intro to quarto
slide will be our our first section
we're going to jump directly into that
and kind of give you this broad overview
of what what quarto looks like
so uh thank you for joining and again
we'll be posting some of the links in
the chat so i'll do my best to kind of
re-emphasize that
also though that these slides are
already public and if you look at the
bottom of any of the slides it will link
back out to that website so if you see a
screenshot of this or want to take a
screenshot it actually has the url built
into each slide
so let's get started we'll go into the
presentation so for the first slide
we're going to say hello cordo so
welcome uh we're using cordo we're going
to be talking all about that today
hopefully you're in the right place uh
here
and we're going to be going through
quite a bit of the syntax and everything
else so we can go on and go to the next
slide
kind of our assumptions for today is
that you know a little bit about r you
probably know a little bit about
markdown
but you're really here to learn about
cordo and maybe you're learning about it
for the first time or maybe you're
learning about it as an extension or the
next generation of our markdown if we
advance the slide one more time we can
see that we'll be teaching you quarto
syntax and quarto formats and more
markdown and even more are along the way
so while you might learn a little bit of
r today we're really focused on that
markdown quarter syntax the formats and
how you can create them
and we can continue forward
if you want to follow me
you can go to follow me on twitter or
github or go to my blog but really you
want to go to cordo.org as the primary
resource for everything you want to
learn about our studio
for the workshop prep
you know again i just want to link out
to the slides in case people see this as
a recording or they see it later on but
we have the content website which has
all the slides as well as links out to
various things and then there's this
full workshop material which again will
go broader than what we're covering
today that was based off the two-day
workshop i gave it our studio conf
the other big thing you want to do is if
you are trying to use
cordo inside our studio you want to be
on the latest version and if you install
2022.07
of our studio it actually comes with a
bundled version of our studio so you're
basically ready to go and you could just
kind of get started working on it
as far as the packages i'm using i also
wanted to list those out so you could
see them and add to them as needed uh
throughout today
we can go forward and we're kind of
ready to get started so we'll go forward
with that and jump into the first kind
of our turn section
these are turns because we're you know
streaming out to several hundred and i
believe eighteen hundred people signed
up
we definitely don't have kind of the
traditional like in-person format of i'm
gonna do it you're gonna do it we're
gonna do it together these are mostly
i'm going to cover a topic provide the
hands-on material so you could do it in
the future or you could play with it but
really kind of think of today as
exploring together getting some kind of
scaffolding put together and then you
can go and play around with it whether
you want to do it locally
and download our studio 2022.07.1
or use them in our studio cloud with all
the workshop materials that are already
installed to that specific link on our
studio cloud
so let's get going we'll go to the next
one
and we're going to be talking about
hello cordo in terms of we talked about
we're getting started with it a
technical definition of cordo is that
it's an open source scientific and
technical publishing system built on
pandoc
that really means that it's open source
just like our markdown so you don't have
to buy anything it's also open source in
terms of you can see all the source code
and you can use it kind of as you wish
it's a technical publishing system which
expands it a little bit farther than our
markdown in terms of cordo and the cordo
command line interface actually allow
you to automatically or kind of connect
to things like netlify or github or
github actions
as well as r studio connect or cordo
pubs so you can publish the things
you're working on and share them whether
that's securely to places with uh
authentication or just to the world wide
web on something like netlify or portal
pubs
as far as how
kind of the mental model for how our
markdown and quarto work we'll start
with a quarto diagram so you may have
heard the words knitter or markdown
knitter originally started in 2011 our
markdown in 2014
and this is the underlying kind of
structure that allows us to execute our
code
uh and generate complex documents from
one single source or the single source
kind of rendering idea
so we first start with a dot rmd or an r
markdown file
that our code in that is evaluated via
knitter and then an intermediary
markdown file is generated that is then
processed by pandoc to generate things
like reports or presentations or
projects
while you may not have really cared what
happened behind the scenes this is
important for like the mental model as
we move into quarto to talk about some
of the differences
the main difference here is that with
our markdown you had a literal r package
called our markdown as well as the
format being dot rmd
the our markdown package and some of the
extension packages things like sharingan
or things like page down or blog down
had additional pre-processing steps that
they were doing in the process of
converting from the plain text rmd out
to a report or presentation or project
for cordo the diagram is going to be
very similar we can actually show that
real quickly move to the next slide
we can say that quarto is really more
than just knitter but still building
upon all these years of experience we
have with them
so we have you know 10 years of literate
programming experience with knitter and
with our markdown we've been developing
it and maintaining it for a long time
if you look at this diagram it actually
looks almost identical to the our
markdown diagram but you may notice two
things number one the dot qmd is the
first item so rather than a dot r
markdown it's a quarto markdown document
and then once we go to the pandoc step
or this conversion layer we have lua
filters or essentially all the
preprocessing that's being done along
with pandoc at the conversion step so
rather than relying on literal r code
and having a mandatory kind of r run
time to execute these documents
by moving the pre-processing onto
pandock and providing lua filters and
other pre-processing outside of a single
language
we can actually go beyond knitter and
use things like julia natively or use
python natively or even javascript or
other languages
so a lot of power here to go beyond just
r but continue with the same mental
model essentially that you had with r
knitter
so let's advance to the next slide
uh when we talk about this being more
than just knitter and we talk about
things like python and talk about julia
we're just replacing one component we're
exchanging maybe our code for python
code or our code for julia code and then
executing them natively via the jupyter
engine
you might be familiar with jupyter as
like an ipython notebook in this case
we're really thinking of it as almost
like a headless process or a kernel
that's executing the code as opposed to
it being the interface that we're using
for our portal document
but your qmd could be almost identical
all you're really doing is changing out
the code steps all of your markdown and
quarto syntax would be the same and
you'd just be changing out the language
model so allowing us to extend to more
than just knitter and more than just r
we can advance the next slide and see
that you know while you might want to
use a plain text format like a dot qmd
you know you're familiar with our our
markdown and that's what you want to use
other teams might actually want to use a
jupiter notebook as their literal
interface
so any of the languages that you can
execute with jupiter we focused really
on python and julia inside jupiter but
any of the languages you can execute in
jupiter can then be again converted to
this markdown rendered with pandoc and
lua filters out to your final report
presentation and project
so ultimately what these diagrams are
telling us is that
regardless of kind of the language your
kind of a structure and how it actually
happens behind the scenes is very
similar and it's really allowing us to
have a shared syntax in a shared format
across
languages and across kind of input
formats
this is expanded upon in the next slide
where we talk about this in a bit more
verbose terms
so just in case you missed the diagram
or you want to kind of have it written
out cordov uses an engine like knitter
to execute code and generate that
temporary output or dot md file
the nd file is processed via pandoc and
quarto's lua filters along with things
like bootstrap css
for html or latex for pdf and then
converted to the final output format
depending upon what you chose
importantly while the quarto teams
provided a lot of different lua filters
and pre-processing steps
other developers in other languages
whether they're written in r or python
or julia can also be applied and in most
situations are interchangeable between
formats and not language specific so you
can write a lua filter that comes from
someone developing a python that helps
out there are developers that are
working in r and vice versa so by moving
the preprocessing into cordo and into
kind of the pandoc native lua filter
we're again getting more interchange and
not requiring one language to do it one
way
the other benefit about what porto
provides is yes cordo can support html
widgets and r and jupiter widgets for
python and julia and this allows you to
have client-side interactivity for your
documents
beyond that though it also allows you to
use native javascript so
we have built-in support for
observable.js
which is a set of enhancements to
vanilla javascript it's by the same team
mike bostock who authored d3 and there's
actually some d3 integration directly
into observable.js
so observable is really powerful because
it has essentially a reactive run time
so it's well suited for interactive data
exploration and analysis um reactive
runtimes are things like
shiny code uh you know that's another
implementation of reactivity and r we
have reactivity here in javascript
that's occurring only on the client side
so here we have an embedded uh
observable kind of little bar
if you go in there and you adjust the
temperature we can switch from say 34
degrees to maybe it's a bit cooler a bit
warmer and we get this real-time
execution of this code only on the
client side so i don't have a server
running to execute this this is all
being done in the browser and you can
get this real-time changes that you're
seeing so you can almost write your own
html widgets on the fly with observable
that's baked into quarto
if we actually advance and look at what
the code looks like
it looks a little bit different yeah
it's some javascript but we're executing
this in an
observable javascript chunk
but it's going to feel again very
similar to writing
code that you might have done with say
something like shiny and you can have it
interact with shinier going further but
allowing you to do this without having
to require a client side or sorry a
server behind it
now while this kind of interaction is
cool we're probably a bit more
interested in something like graphics or
kind of reactive graphics so on the next
slide we actually have
some graphics and then a widget that we
can interact with it and again this is
done all through porto via the help of
observable.js
so if we click on the dream tag
underneath islands at the top right
we can actually add in new data back to
this so now for this penguin data set we
actually have all the different penguins
available here across all the different
islands and then we can adjust the bill
length and get real-time changes that
are observed inside
the graphics itself
so whether you're working in r or python
or javascript or anywhere else you have
this ability to mix and merge between
the different languages and have things
interact and have all this client-side
interactivity
so
this really means that cordo is a big
universe it's not just r anymore you
know it's not just python or not just
julia it's really thinking about how do
we serve all these different communities
and bring in things that you might not
even thought about in terms of there's a
lot of power in things like javascript
and observable that are also useful to
use in your data science products
ultimately quarto is kind of the part
here in the middle that's providing this
structure of allowing you to use r and
python and julian observable together
and create very complex and beautiful
documents at the end
so rather than thinking about okay i
wrote my stuff in r and i wrote myself
in python and i have to generate a
website and then i have to go generate a
word document and i have to redo all my
work by working through cordo you can
essentially have some of this single
source publishing and have the ability
to generate documents and websites and
presentations all through the shared
syntax regardless of the language you're
working in
on the next slide we talk a little bit
more about what cordo actually is you
know i've talked about all these
exciting things but what is cordo in
terms of breaking it down so porto
itself is a command line interface so
rather than again being just in our
package or just a python package or
library it's a language agnostic command
line interface so you don't even need
any language on your computer to install
it you could just install it as a
terminal at your terminal as a command
line interface and just use whatever
language you want and add on to it
if we click through a little bit
to see
what the next part is we can actually
execute a little bit of the code so we
can step through and see the version so
if we click the right arrow button we
can uh
see that you can call things like portal
help at the terminal or you can go
through and see the different help
that's how i'm displaying the text here
i can also do things like cordo render
to actually render out my document or
cordo preview which allows me to preview
the document and maintain a background
server so that as changes are made i can
actually see those live and kind of have
a
real-time feedback as i'm writing my
documents
what this really means in terms of
portal being a command line interface is
it's not tied into one tool obviously i
love using rstudio and that's what i'm
gonna be showing a lot of today so i can
advance and see that yeah you know
here's our studio it might be a little
bit small for you to read everything but
it's gonna feel very similar in a great
way as your experience with markdown and
with our markdown
there's a lot of enhancements that cordo
provides on top of it but you don't have
to relearn the wheel just to use it
however if you go to your colleagues and
they say well i've never used rstudio
i'm not familiar with that i use this
other tool maybe they prefer something
like a jupiter notebook or jupiter lab
you can also use cordo as a command line
interface in jupiter or with jupiter lab
so you can actually write literal dot
ipython notebooks and then render those
out to portal documents as well so
you're not limited just to the rstudio
interface
and for certain other people they're
like well i kind of like notebooks but i
don't want to write in jupyter for some
reason they're choosing a different
interface
you can also use vs code and this way
regardless of what kind of editor you're
using you're able to you know meet in
the middle and collaborate with your
colleagues and say i'm using porto
you're using porto but you're not
limited to one interface or one language
this kind of comes out a lot of times
with the customers that i'm working with
and if we think about you know the
different interfaces this aligns with a
lot of the most common open source
interfaces and again building on this
idea of not just limiting it to one
language or one editor but trying to
create something that's bigger than just
our studio you know it's providing value
for other communities besides just the
art community
now that being said we obviously have
spent a lot of time you know building
cordo into these different tools and
enhancing them as much as possible
so you can actually inside our studio
have the visual editor mode what this
allows you to do is actually get
real-time conversion of just the
markdown and some of the css and see
what that looks like
so rather than only looking at the plain
text we're only looking at
the rendered output once you kind of
finalized your document
with the visual mode you can actually
see again in literal real time the
conversion of markdown or latex or css
or even creating tables and graphics
what they look like inside the body of
the document
so a lot of power here to not only write
your documents but have a better writing
experience so there's even things like
adding bold text or inserting tables or
graphics built into the editor and
allowing you to have this rich
experience inside our studio
again you'll want to be on the latest
version
2022.07.1 of our studio provides all
these integrations and while you can use
cordo in older versions of our studio
some of the enhancements came at this
most recent version from our studio conf
now to explore what the visual editor
looks like we actually have a workshop
material so underneath the 03 authoring
visual editor there's the ability to
kind of go through
the visual editor mode
and you can click around and see like
some of these things and how they look
like so includes things like citations
or the ui elements as well as the visual
editing mode and you can turn it on and
off to explore the the sections
if we go back one slide
and we look at the visual editor mode we
can click
the opt button or the control button and
click on the middle of the page right
around the render button
and that'll actually zoom in on the page
a little bit
but it's okay if we can't get there
we're working on some things
so
going on to talk a little bit about the
other editors again we don't want to
just limit these enhancements to
something like our studio we want to
have a really good experience in any
editor so again you're not limited to
our studio but there's a lot of power
there
if you are coming from say the vs code
world or you that's the tool you want to
use there's a vs code extension that
allows you to get both the syntax
highlighting and some of the auto
completion and
yaml linting and other things built into
vs code and when you render something
you get in this little pop-up page and
have kind of the side-by-side experience
that you're familiar with
this also applies to things like yaml so
if you've used ipython notebooks you may
not write yaml in them because you know
the ipython notebook or the jupiter
notebook doesn't really care about the
yaml it doesn't change what the jupiter
notebook does but it's really important
for quarto
so you can write these as a raw chunk in
a jupiter notebook and again you can use
jupiter or jupiter lab as your interface
you're not limited to a plain text
format although i really like plain text
formats like doc qmd
you can again use an ipython notebook as
your kind of editor of choice if that's
the way you want it to go
we also have yaml intelligence so this
is obviously built into our studio but
also within vs code it has auto
completion through the vs code extension
for things like
different yaml options so not only will
help you find out what are the options
you can change but it'll help you define
them and then input them as well as the
outputs you can do for them so here for
theme we might you know start typing th
and then we can auto tab complete to
theme and then it'll let us see that we
have things available like cosmo or
litera or other different bootswatch
themes that are available
for jupiter and jupiter lab again most
of what this will look like is rather
than having the auto completion you have
a little bit less kind of interactivity
in the yaml because the yaml is not
something that jupiter is normally
working with so it's a literal raw chunk
and we can use that to say okay this is
what the the interface looks like uh and
you can still type the same figure
chunks and the same kind of syntax but
the yaml itself will be essentially
ignored by the jupiter notebook
if we're using um
cordo or cordo
preview or any other commands within
jupiter from the terminal we would call
something like porto preview on our
specific notebook so quarto preview
notebook.ipython notebook and then we're
saying preview it or convert it to html
when we do this it'll pop up a
background screen so that again we can
have our side-by-side output so while
you're editing the document you can save
and get the re-rendered output very very
quickly
from the terminal but also having it
available as a separate pane
again kind of talked about this a few
times but just want to be very clear
that yaml needs to be a raw cell in
jupiter jupiter doesn't really care
about the yaml but it's needed and used
exclusively by quarto for these changes
so why did we talk all this time about
different editors again i think part of
it is that we're talking about porto for
collaboration and cordo for more than
one community really like a data science
team or across data science teams
so you might have a website or a data
science project or a quarto project that
has something like this
you might have a data lake and you're
extracting some data with the s3 package
and doing dplyr to do some extraction
and data cleaning on it with an older
our markdown document you already wrote
and then you're doing some additional
data cleaning from one of your python
colleagues who knows suba and is writing
you know python code to edit that
document
then it's handed back off and we're
working from python and r and then we're
just doing some general exploratory data
analysis in it
and then lastly we have a traditional
dot qmd and we're using the torch
package and r to do some computer vision
or classification of the images
identifying what they are
so regardless of kind of the different
structures you have you have some r
markdown you have some jupiter notebooks
you have some qmds across any of these
editors and across these different kind
of input formats you can create or
aggregate them via quarto into an
overall project or to convert them over
to complex outputs regardless of what
you need
so a lot of power here for collaboration
the other part is eventually you're
going to want to get whatever you have
off of your machine so you can use the
quarto publish command and that'll
actually allow you to take a document or
a website or presentation or something
else you've created and then publish it
somewhere off of your computer
so we have built-in support for quarto
pub which is a website that our studio
provides as a free service and you can
actually sign up today for quarter.pub
get your handle and start publishing
there for free
or you could do something like a github
pages branch uh and publish things to
github pages kind of like how i'm
hosting some of my slides today
you can even use rstudio connect so if
you have connect on premise or in your
cloud you can publish there and have
authentication and have it work across
your whole enterprise or something like
netlify which again has a pretty
generous free tier allowing you to
publish websites and other html content
to them so regardless of where you're
publishing it again cordo is extending
the idea of our markdown to being a
publishing or kind of this bigger
project not just creating things locally
but also baking in the ability to uh
publish all sorts of different things so
lots of different things that you can
create and then share out with the world
as far as for this idea of like data
science and work
so for a lot of our customers they're
using rstudio workbench and our studio
connect you'll want to use the latest
versions so 2022.07.1
and
2022.07.0
these versions um allow for all the
latest and greatest integrations of
cordo you can use cordo with older
versions but some of the latest stuff
was built in recently
this diagram here i'm not really going
to go into all the details but just kind
of an overview is that you can use
quarto and our markdown together and
publish these complex kind of pipelines
as needed on something like rstudio
connect for re-execution or rescheduling
of quarto documents and using them
inside an enterprise environment with
enterprise-grade authentication and
sharing
one of the last kind of initial core
parts of what cordo provides is that
porto is fully batteries included so if
you just install rstudio
2022.07.1 it comes pre-installed and
loaded with a version of cordo
so you don't really need to install
anything else you're ready to go you
know you can just get started working
with cordo and you don't have to worry
about you know installing a bunch of
different r packages to support cordo
it's just there and always available and
will be available moving forward in new
versions of the rstudio ide
so very exciting moment of like having
this be available it coincided with our
studio conf
and having it baked in just allows you
to get started faster and collaborate
better as you're not having to do
additional installs
this battery's included idea goes beyond
just having it available
rather than requiring you know a bunch
of different installs of different
packages
again all these different formats are
baked into quarto so your basic formats
like html pdf docx presentations with
powerpoint or the ones i did today with
reveal.js
or even advanced layout or websites
you can also do cross-referencing and
writing entire books or blogs or
interactive and combining
shiny
things together you have all these
different formats that are just there
and already available you don't have to
like install something new
the one thing i do want to note though
is that there's three things that we're
really keen on adding into cordo and
again these will be added into the
single install in the future
so page down or page html basically the
ability to create pdf without latex and
only using css
journal articles and most of that work
has already been completed so you can
actually use cordo to publish to a lot
of different journal formats
and then flex dashboard is one that a
lot of people are really keen on and
that's also something we plan on having
very shortly for allowing me to create
entire dashboards uh through quarto
alone and again those those dashboards
could include shiny they could include
javascript or widgets you can kind of
build them as complex or as simple as
you'd like
but core idea here is batteries included
and rather than having to install
additional libraries it's one install
with all these things included
now at this point you might be saying
like oh this is a lot of exciting things
but i have a lot of our markdown
documents and ipython notebooks and
jupiter notebooks that i wrote before i
heard about cordo you know what do i do
with those so for some of you if you
have existing work or you're still
working in our markdown jupiter you can
just keep working in them
you know you can still use our markdown
to render them out or to knit them
but if you wanted to you could still use
cordo to render your documents out
so you could use cordo render on an
existing dot our markdown file and
render it out to something like html and
it'll render it out to html so for the
most part our markdown documents will
convert over as they are
you don't have to you don't have to
change the syntax while you can change
the syntax to be more aligned with all
the features that cordo is adding but
again for older documents where you
don't want to edit them for the most
part you can just render them over
and similarly with jupyter notebooks you
can also render them via the command
line terminal so quarto render on your
existing jupiter notebook to a specific
format
the additional argument that we see here
dash dash execute at the end of that
call
basically says take my jupyter notebook
and re-execute it from top to bottom
like a linear document
but you can make it be where don't
re-execute it and just take the stored
computation that's already been
evaluated in your document
whereas our markdown and quarto
documents are plain text and any
rendering is done kind of as it's being
generated with jupyter notebooks you
actually can store some computation
inside the notebook
so you have this option of re-execution
or just reuse of the existing
computation that's occurred what chordo
is doing is the conversion step of the
notebook or the r markdown to a final
output format like html or pdf or
website
so to summarize kind of a bit about this
like why would you be interested in
cordo
number one batteries included with the
shared syntax so batteries included in
terms of it's installed with our studio
so it's always available
if you're in another language though or
using a different editor you have this
shared syntax across r and python and
julia and javascript
and based off that you get to choose
your own editor and your preferred data
science language and for many of you and
myself included like i'm still using our
studio and i love our studio but if you
need to collaborate with someone who's
using a different tool you can still do
that without having to change into a
whole new thing y'all can collaborate on
a shared format
it also has better accessibility and
richer features built in out of the box
so there's been a lot of effort for kind
of ally work with accessibility
availability to add things like
alternative text and aria tags and all
sorts of kind of best practices that
we're building into cordo
so you can of course you know add on to
those but we've tried to provide best
practices for you out of the box
and ultimately while our markdown is
still being maintained and we have no
plans to deprecate it or remove it
we're building most of our new features
into knitter and into cordo itself so
over time cordo's going to keep
expanding
this might sound counter-intuitive to
you in terms of knitters used by both
our markdown and cordo so you might have
some enhancements going back to our
markdown world but in reality when you
think of extending our markdown that
would be writing a new package
the core arm markdown package itself
you know it's been very stable for a
long time you have things like page down
or book down or blog down that are
additional packages adding additional
functionality
so what quarto is providing here is
again that batteries included and rather
than adding on new packages over time
they're added into the core install of
cordo so lots of exciting things you can
do with cordo out of the box
and ultimately this means that when you
collaborate or work with others in
different languages again you have this
shared format ability to choose your own
editor and work in your native language
whatever that is
i've talked a little bit about rendering
but i just want to be very clear in
terms of there's different ways to
render and using command line interfaces
might be something new for a lot of you
i don't want to ignore that
so inside our studio you can always use
the render button the render button is
right in the exact same place where you
would have seen the knit button for our
markdown but now it's called render
because it's consistently rendering
across different documents
you can also use the terminal or the
system shell via cordo render so here
whether it's in just a random terminal
on your computer or the integrated
terminal or command line inside our
studio or another editor you can call
cordo render and then render the
document out and choose a specific
format that you want to render it out to
and then lastly if you really want to
use the r package or there's some kind
of workflow and we'll talk a little bit
about those where you need to render it
out to a different format you can use
the r package to take a document and
render it out so just as you would have
used our markdown colon colon render
you can use cordo colon colon quarter
render to do similar workflows that
you'd like to do
and you can choose the output format and
provide parameterization and other
things that you'd expect via the package
or via the
command line interface
ultimately what we're trying to talk
about here is this change of your mental
model so maybe you're fully bought into
our markdown maybe you haven't even
thought about it but really what we're
saying is rather than treating your
exact source document and your output
document is the same thing like you do
with something like microsoft office or
microsoft word
where changes you make are unable to be
tracked
we're talking about using code and then
a source document and an output document
so with the source document we have
plain text so you know we have yaml and
we have markdown and then different code
that's at the bottom here
and when we render this out we get a
separate document that actually is
generated as the output
so when you're working with something
like version control or you're just
trying to figure out how did i even
create this document you have the
literal source code saying this is how i
got there and then this is what i
generated so you can still have
artifacts that you're creating over time
even though the source code of the data
might be changing as you move along you
can always try and recreate it or
reproduce the work you've done
when we think about a dot qmd which is
what we're going to focus on for the
remainder of today a qmd file is plain
text so you have metadata with you know
choosing a format or choosing an engine
obviously we can choose knitter and
stick with r or we can choose jupiter
and do something in julia or python
then we execute some code
so we've chosen our format we've got
some code in our python we want to
execute we go through here and we group
by summarize on empty cars everyone's
favorite data set that's kind of built
in or a boring little data set but then
we can also add text to this so rather
than just executing code we can add
markdown text and do things like adding
alternative text to images or bolding
the text or italicizing text or adding
headers or subsections but overall you
can still read this in its plain text
format but it's indicating this is the
markdown or the markup to generate an
output format in bold or italics or
other things
the metadata or that yaml at the top is
what's controlling the overall rendering
process so this tells you what is the
output format i want to do what kind of
table of contents do i want to do what
are all the different things that i want
to do across the entire document as it
goes
and again this can affect things like
the code or just the content the
rendering process or how it appears
and it's usually read across by all the
different components so it interacts
with pandoc and interacts with cordo and
interacts with knitter and affects all
the different processes over time
what the yaml actually looks like is
you'd have something like this it's
indicated with three dashes at the top
and you do something like what is the
title of my document and then most
importantly choosing a format coming
from our markdown you might have been
familiar with the output
here we're always going to indicate that
as format and then we can do something
like html
add a table of contents and say that
it's true and then add code folding so
while the code is available it's hidden
behind a little details tag that can be
opened or closed
but most importantly you have three
dashes at the top three dashes at the
bottom and that indicates the opening
and closing of your document as you move
forward
the markdown components is based again
on pandoc pandoc is ultimately the tool
that's behind the scenes being
converting it out to other formats
and pandec markdown is very rich
um so you can have
you know not just the most basic
markdown but really really ex
kind of expansive markdown that allows
you to do layout and kind of structuring
of the document overall
so it's based on john gruber's markdown
syntax and it has the importance of
being plain text so that it's easy to
read and easy to write and when you
check it into something like version
control your diffs are very easy to also
read and write so rather than a whole
document changing if you change one or
two lines
the structure is just where you can see
the diffs and the different portions
that are changed in source control as
well
markdown might do things like italics or
bold or superscript strikethrough or
even displaying verbatim code
so this allows you to write again like
lots of different markup about what
you're doing and while you're looking at
even just the plain text you can also
kind of imagine what that's going to
look like in the output format and again
if you're using our studio with the
visual editor mode you can also
render or essentially like preview what
all the different parts are in real time
by switching from source mode to visual
mode
importantly there's also the idea of
headers in markdown and pandoc markdown
so these allow you to break up a
document by adding pound signs in front
of text and say you know this is a head
section and then you can build up
subsections within each of those so you
can write out your headers and do
overall complex kind of layouts of your
document
as for code and there was a good
question i saw in the chat so
with knitter you can execute our code
and python code together that would be
using reticulate and that's an important
idea like we you can merge them both
into the same document
so here i have a code chunk it's just
executing r but via reticulate i could
execute r and python code together
if i wanted to use python alone i can
use jupyter as my engine and r doesn't
have to be involved in that process so
you don't have to go to a python
colleague and tell them hey you know
there's this cool tool we could
collaborate on but you have to install r
and you have to use our packages to
manage it they can just use it in their
native language without having to
install anything else
we're going to talk a little bit more
about what code chunks actually build up
with in the second half of today
but you might notice that there's this
hash pipe syntax at the top indicating
the chunk options as opposed to putting
them into the chunk label where they
might have been before
but regardless you have this ability to
in a portal document just like i'm
working on today
write code that generates outputs
and it can do more than just r and you
can actually have um
you know insertion of graphics in
matplotlib or using numpy so again we
can mix r and python together and
knitter with reticulate or we could have
a python pure document that's using just
jupiter as this engine and doesn't have
to have r in the full process so it's
more than just r and you're able to
collaborate with your colleagues
as far as the command line interface
again you can call cordo dash help
inside your terminal and that will open
up a lot of different things for
rendering the documents out and display
some of the features that are available
most importantly you want to make sure
we're going to be on like
1.0.35 or more recent that is kind of
the 1.0 stable release and that's what's
bundled into our studio as well as in
our studio cloud
if you wanted to see the help from the
terminal it would again be quarto space
dash dash help that will open up the
help page that you see here
and the two most common things you're
going to use are chordo render and
quarto preview which allow you to kind
of generate the document or preview the
document out to a different format
for some of you
working the command line may not be
something you're you're used to but for
others it might be like oh yeah that's
great i love using command line tools if
you wanted to go really deep into
understanding like how to use different
command line
calls or work through different things
the data carpentries has a link here on
the page
that goes out to a great workshop they
have
or there's a tool called tldr that
allows you to kind of ask questions and
say like what is this tool like how does
it work
i did want to include some really common
uh commands just so you have them
available things like printing the
working directory or changing the
directory so you can move between
folders
list the directory contents with ls
ask cordo what are the different things
i can do with corto-help
make a directory or remove a directory
allowing you to kind of work through all
these different things you're able to
so
while you may not have to work in the
command line interface just wanted to
provide these as
helpers for if you need to
if you want to go into kind of the first
part there's this ability to render and
it kind of walks you through rendering a
document with the render button and
ultimately with this 01 intro
history.qmd
we're recreating a an article about
boston terriers and recreating it with
this single source
so we have that ability to create a
specific document
render it out to
html and a pdf and see the differences
and compare them
so that was the first section we still
have about an hour left that we're going
to do in the second section but because
it's a little bit longer today i do want
to take a five minute break
so we're gonna meet back here at 11 55
my time which might be different for you
but we will
prompt you back here in five minutes so
uh five minutes past the uh 10 minute
mark here
so we'll pause for a second
yeah we'll leave this up i'll answer
some of the questions that are popping
up in the chat i do want to address some
of those but just give you a break if
you need to use the bathroom or get a
drink of water or anything else
and i just wanted to say i know for some
reason youtube was blocking the slido
link when we were trying to share it so
i can share that on the screen as well
if you want to be able to ask anonymous
questions too
while we may not get to every single
question we are definitely going to take
those and
answer them in a follow-up blog post and
other formats as well
i do so part of the reason why i really
appreciate rachel being here is she's
helping out a lot and for some reason my
computer decided it wanted to share
things a bit blurrier so while i'm not
going to be driving everything on my
screen if you're looking at it right now
it might look a little bit blurry which
is kind of why rachel's being kind
enough to
to lead the example
um but i just want to mention that in
our studio if you've never used it
before there's the r console
at the very bottom left typically here
or there's the uh actual command line
terminal
so if we wanted to we can obviously like
switch between r and you know one plus
one and you can execute our code from
the terminal is where you'd actually say
something like quarto dash help and then
it'll pop up all the different commands
that the quarto can run so that's where
you're going to be looking for it is the
terminal inside our studio
the other
main feature is that cordo.org and i'll
drop that link into the chat
it is an amazing resource and it has a
really strong search bar here at the top
right you can you know search for
whatever you want to learn about and ask
questions there
ultimately it has the get started tab
that allows you to explore different
things
and you know get started just out of the
gates or the guide is much more guided
in terms of specific topic and the
different things that you want to ask
so there was someone who asked can i run
the court of cli at the terminal inside
our studio absolutely that is what we're
expecting people who are using our
studio to do is use the integrated
terminal
but for other editors like vs code or
jupiter you might use a separate
terminal or spin up a new terminal
kind of ad hoc as needed
there were a couple questions about
different formats
so you can change those via the yaml
or you can do it via the command line
interface
so again if i wanted to render a
document and part of the example that
we're working on here is in the quarto
workshop under intro we have this dot
qmd file
if i want to i can just say quarto
render
01
intro
actually let's move into that directory
another good example of let's list and
see where we are we're in quarter
workshop let's do quarto workshop
one dot intro so i'm moving or changing
the directory into this sub folder
i can quarta render history.qnb
and it's going to render it out to an
html format
or in this case because i've changed it
to a pdf initially so it'll render it
out i've got a pdf
i can pull that up in my browser
make it a lot bigger and while it's a
little bit blurry on my screen
you can see that we have a pretty nice
looking pdf document with some pretty
complex type setting and using images in
around the text as well as in the
sidebar
if i instead wanted to render that to
html i could say quarto render
let's say history dot qmd
to html
when i render it this way now rather
than rendering it to the default of pdf
i get an html file
and i pull that up and we'll get it as
self-contained
let's do
qmd
apologies i'm very zoomed in because i
want you all to be able to see
the content here so in the yaml i can
render that html out
render that and i have these similar
looking complex layout in html
now while you didn't see any of the real
code in that document and it again i
apologize for being a bit blurry we'll
jump back into slides here in a second
what we're trying to take away here is
that i wrote no latex and i wrote no css
i only used cordo to typeset this
document
so cordo has a lot of information that
are kind of structuring it's building in
to build things in different formats so
it's opinionated in a good way to give
you nice defaults
for some people
who are asking and it's a great question
if i'm in the terminal
on linux or on mac let me clear this out
do a new terminal
zoom out just a hair there
so i can call cordo render on something
on some flavors of windows you have to
do quarto dot command this is a very
specific thing on
different flavors of the terminal and in
some cases on windows especially you
might have to use quarto dot command and
then you can do something like help on
linux it's not going to understand that
but inside the powershell or inside um
git bash flavored
terminal inside windows you might have
to name space that
so great question rebecca thank you for
for indicating that
so while i would love to screen share
everything it again is a bit blurry on
my side so i'm going to hand it back
over to rachel and i'm going to move
back into the slides here in about a
minute
i'm going to stop screen sharing mine
and move over to rachel's screen sharing
if you want to pull up the slides again
we'll do one second that's good do you
need a second to go grab some water or
anything
i got my water right here okay
thanks for sticking around now
so um
we're gonna switch back over to rachel's
component and i'll stop screen sharing
mine i was also going to say tom if you
want me to walk through our studio cloud
and just to share that on my screen
happy to do that as well and switch back
and forth sure yeah if you want to share
uh our studio cloud um happy to if you
want to zoom in a bit we can walk
through it
so kind together
like a live workshop here for me which i
have no idea what's doing right now
thanks for sticking with it rachel so
rachel has opened up the rstudio cloud
link and we'll drop that into the chat
here in a second let me grab the
workshop component
uh grab that link i put it into the chat
you can't actually click on it on the
screen but it should be showing up in
youtube right now yeah and rachel also
put it into the restream chat so it
should be available um oh sorry i'll
show that again
so this if you go that route allows you
to essentially get started immediately
with the workshop materials as we see
them
so you don't have to install additional
things for what i was working on i was
going into 01-intro
on the file pin
got it and then clicking on history.qmd
perfect i'm going to move us out of the
way a little bit oh that's a little bit
too big there we go
um and you can see inside the file pane
that we have a couple images the files
of pdf and html you can always use the
render button so at the top left of the
qmd you're in the middle there's a
render button you're welcome to use that
and that's where most people are going
to be the most familiar with using it
you're absolutely able to click that
okay
if you click on it it'll render the
document out great we have our lovely
boston terriers uh basically this is not
howard but i pretend it's howard my dog
and he's up on the screen
and if we wanted to change it to pdf we
could actually just go back to our
studio cloud
and inside the yaml underneath i think
your dog just heard his name actually he
did he started shaking a little bit he's
excited
uh so on line five it says html
if we delete that and type in pdf and
then a colon
yep
awesome and then save and render it
again
now we'll actually render out a pdf
and again part of
the excitement of cordo is that i don't
know any latex like that's just not a
thing i do
um it's giving rachel a pop-up saying i
wanna you know pull us into the browser
automatically and that's fine it's
nothing to be worried about it's just
trying to protect you
but now we have that same document
rendered to pdf
and again rachel and i didn't have to
write any latex or any pdf specific
things we just use quarto syntax so you
can imagine that i'm writing a journal
article and i want to create a website
and i want to create a journal article
that actually submit to the publisher
both of those could go from essentially
the same single source
and you could write it in a way and have
it render out without having to write
all the manual latex or write all the
manual css to typeset it and make it
look really good
um i also saw someone mentioned about
the
specifics for the folder structure yes
the i brought in all the files from the
two-day workshop i gave at our studio
conf i didn't want to limit y'all just
the things i can cover in the next hour
but rather give you some of the other
formats and other kind of approaches
that we can do for documents over
everything
so with that we're at our five minute
mark rachel thanks for walking through
our studio cloud with me that's a lot of
fun and we'll go back to the slides and
i'll move us to the bottom right so that
we can uh not overlap with it too much
awesome
also pretty cool that i can just log
into our studio cloud there without
having to install anything and it just
worked
yeah absolutely that definitely helps
with having to swap who's the presenter
for today
so let me uh also get my slides aligned
with you if you click at the bottom and
again the link that we're working off of
we'll drop that into the chat the
overall website is available here
i'll keep that up on the screen for a
little bit
and tom which which link should i be
clicking on right now
the quarter two hour webinar um
so it should be i think that's link one
or two oh sorry you're on the two day
workshop page that has all the content
uh
let me share it with you
dropping it into your chat there
on the side
in the restream chat
yeah
there we go awesome we have a lot of
links here yes
i wanted to give y'all as much content
as possible and while i'm trying to
cover a good chunk of it obviously
there's a lot of things you can do uh
afterwards after today is finished
perfect so now that uh rachel's back on
the primary website we've completed
intro to cordo and we're going to talk a
bit more about author and cordo
so the on the top left we have author
and cordo and we're going to go through
that together
okay i'll send myself backstage here
sounds good thanks so much rachel
so ultimately like you know
again we covered a little bit of the
high details but went through them
pretty quickly so now we're going to
spend a bit more time talking about how
to actually do things as opposed to just
about what you can do
so we're going to talk about quarter
documents mainly about this anatomy
we're going to go through yaml talk
about the different ways you can create
formats we're going to talk about
markdown and text
and you know creating that over to the
documents that you're rendering out and
then using code so using things like
knitter jupiter to execute r or python
or julia code
you add all these things together and
you have those beautiful powerful useful
outputs and again you're creating them
with a plain text input so you don't
have to write all the different things
while you can embed raw css and raw
latex and all these other different
things into it
quarto provides a lot of power to do all
that just through what's built into
cordo
this is really an extension of the idea
of literate programming basically the
idea of writing out program logic in a
human language with included code
snippets and macros
so if we look at a plain text document
like we have here on the page or a qmd
we have the title which is highlighted
here in purple that's the yaml and all
the different metadata about the
document
we have yellow or kind of this off pink
here that is highlighting the you know
the air quality the relationship between
temperature and ozone level basically
the markdown that you're working on
and then the code which is highlighted
here by the r chunk and it has a label
of figure air quality as well as some
code to generate a graphic via ggplot
so this idea of literate programming
allows us to build up different
components
and you know write out the document as
you'd like in real time in a linear way
like top to bottom but structure it and
add up all the the actual literate part
in additional to the code that you're
writing
so first we'll kick off with metadata or
that yaml that's at the top
metadata or what's called yaml you could
say it's yet another markup language or
yaml and markup language or whatever you
want to say it follows a structure of
these key value pairs so you have a key
something like title and then you have
the value you're inputting something
like this is my first quarto document
and you're putting that in as text
that's the general structure that all
the yama will follow of just matching
you know some in option with what the
option you've chosen
so we think about like output options
going to the next slide we have format
is something so format is the keyword
that's saying this is the format we're
choosing to render to and the value is
something we're choosing
now we're not going to say something
we're going to choose something like
html or pdf or for today's slides i used
reveal js
to create these interactive html slides
that allow me to step through it
and again it's you know available
through
open source so it's not something else i
have to install or something else i have
to buy it's all built into that as a
different format
you can also add option arguments or
kind of sub commands to this so i'm not
limited to just saying html and then i'm
done for the day i could say i have a
format and then i go down to a new line
and i have html and then on the next
line i have table of contents equals
true and code folding google's true so
again i can control the structure or
control the options within my format by
adding these sub options to it
sub options are going to be below this
is slightly cut off in terms of if you
click f rachel to go full screen for you
so it's gonna have the sub options of
option one and option two
the options are not limited to just
plain text or just you know uh logicals
like true and false but they can be a
mixing and matching so some options
might be logicals like true false or
other
some might be text where you're having
to quote it and that's okay it's just
depending upon what the options are that
you're editing
now as far as why you would actually
choose yaml
is that you might need to avoid manually
typing out all these different options
you know if i just have a document like
we showed in our studio cloud it's
pretty easy to say cordo render document
to html yep i got that that's easy
enough where i can have fun with it and
change it around
but if i wanted to start adding
additional things i can do those via the
command line but it gets a bit tricky in
terms of like portal render document to
html add some options where code and
folding is equal to true not too bad
but then i have something really long
and i have this like quarter render
document with code folding parameters
and it's running off the page it's it's
too long
so while you can absolutely use that
maybe you have it in like continuous
integration or something else
it's much easier to write this via yaml
and that's why the yaml is provided is
to structure these different options
now as far as navigating within our
studio um i might walk again rachel
through this in our studio cloud if you
want to click escape it'll get you out
of full screen
and then you go back to rstudio cloud
for anyone that missed this before i
just want to point out where the console
and where the terminal is
so at the bottom left we have the r
console where you execute our code or
you load packages or whatever else you
want to do
and then right next to it on the tab is
a word called terminal
and so if you click on terminal next to
console on the bottom left now you're at
a command line interface or at the
terminal inside rstudio cloud although
it might be organized a bit differently
on your specific computer
that's where you could execute the cordo
command line interface as opposed to the
r package that would be executed inside
the r console or in a dot r or qmd file
so just want to make sure that we have
that differentiation between the
terminal exists you can execute code
there if you just installed cordo you
might need to restart our studio for
example like if you install them
separately or if you're making changes
you typically want to refresh to make
sure everything's available
let's go back to the slides real quick
now we've covered the navigation
perfect the other part you might see is
that when you click say the render
button in our studio it's actually going
to open up what's called a background
job now here rather than rachel having
to go and navigate to our studio cloud
i've got a screenshot for you
it's going to start this and maintain a
background job for you part of why it
does this is when you click the render
button in our studio it both renders the
document out and then maintains a
stateful browser or
kind of web server in the background so
as you make changes you can re-render it
and get the full thing built up together
so this is really useful for things like
websites or building out complex
structures where you're adding a lot of
different components and you want to see
how they all interact
if you did something via the r console
it would actually execute just as it was
and render out the document without the
background job
or if you executed something via the
terminal it would just execute it via
the terminal and not create a background
job
but the quarto render button
specifically will start this background
job and maintain it in the background
you could always kill it off or stop it
if you wanted to
stop that from being rendered in the
back
for today i saw a couple questions about
the recording so this is on youtube
right now and you can access it in the
future via youtube as well so it'll be
both the live version that you're
watching right now and the recorded
version will both live on youtube at the
link you're at right now
again for rendering if you click that
render button that's where you get the
background job
but you can also call it via the
terminal and cordo render or via the r
console
via the quarto r package and calling
quarto underscore render
so all these are valid there's not
really a requirement to do it one way or
the other just part of it is what are
you needing to do like you trying to
render a document two different formats
you could do that very easily via the
terminal or the r package without having
to
modify the document but maybe the render
button inside our studio is the easiest
for you to get started with out of the
gate and you don't have to have to learn
about
rendering out via the terminal
so the
other component again someone brought up
the good point that uh underneath the
workshop it's slightly different
structure but the workshop material is
the visual editor.qmd mode this allows
you to again see some of the differences
so you can try rendering this via the
cli
or the command line interface via the r
package or with the rstudio render
button
it also is a good example of what visual
mode looks like so this is another good
opportunity for rachel to hop into our
studio cloud and we're going to briefly
look through
the
visual mode button so if you go to the
files pane click on quarto workshop
on the bottom right
i'm going to come back here just in case
you need to hear anything okay perfect
perfect um so going to files
yep if you go to the cordo workshop um
at the top
it says cloud project quarter workshop
perfect
and then on the computation folder so o3
computation
awesome and should we switch the screen
so people can see about our faces there
we go great call
computation
yeah
and then there's a visual editor.qmd
file that you can click on
yep
so in that one again if you kind of
pull that tab to be a bit larger so if
you grab between the right panel and the
left panel right in the middle of
everything yep right there and drag it
over
and then zoom in one more time
so this is a plain text document right
now because we're in source mode so if
rachel were to scroll down you would see
literal
plain text you'd see a code chunk you'd
see a bunch of different things going on
and literal markdown
if she instead clicks on the visual
button so at the top left there's source
versus visual
it'll convert the document and kind of
show it it's going to pop up this page
which is great it says like switching to
visual mode what is going on and it
walks you through what that is let's
just click use visual mode
and now the yama will look the same but
if she were to scroll down
uh we'll see code chunk which is great
we can still execute code but now we
have literal text that is rendered as
you'd expect it so you have headers and
hyperlinks and all the other different
things that you're actually creating
so without having to rendering the
document visual markdown mode allows you
to
see what the output would look like
without having to render and execute all
the code
it also has things like insertion of
graphics you can paste images in there
you could copy an image and just paste
it and it'll automatically create it you
can insert citations and tables and it
has shortcuts for bolding text and
italicizing text and all the other
things that you expect for a writing
kind of a document that you want to work
on
so there's a lot in there and we're not
going to cover like the whole thing but
it would allow you to see all of the
different components of what the visual
mode can change
great question someone's asking about
the hyperlink i think you have that one
rachel i can paste it yep i just
reshared it on restream
i'll share it for a second here too
awesome stuff
thanks rachel cool so that's visual mode
but just wanted to say it's amazing it
you could do an entire two hours on just
visual mode um but go play around with
it and you can kind of see what it looks
like in real time without having to
render the whole thing out
so let's hop back into the slides
i've got a couple boston terriers pulled
up on my page i'm going to close those
down
and all right so we're on slide 12 now
the other part of what a quarto provides
and this is a huge improvement from
before is
yaml linting
so you can imagine that while yaml is
very helpful not all of us write yaml
all the time so we can actually get uh
linting or kind of saying hey a mistake
was made and this is what we think the
mistake is
and if we click the arrow we can
actually uh show that the images are
popping up on the screen there we go
and it's got uh these basically saying
hey an error occurred and this is what i
think the way to solve it is
so inside both our studio and inside vs
code with the quarto extension uh you
get this real-time kind of feedback
that's saying hey you made a mistake in
the ammo here's what we think you can do
to fix it a key format has an empty
value basically you need to put in what
is the format you're rendering to
it will do this after a delay so it's
not always going to pop up immediately
that you've left it blank because you're
typing but if you wait long enough or
save the document with a mistake or this
error then it will give you this warning
and tell you hey here's how we think you
can fix it
it also has something called yaml
intelligence so this allows you to do
tab completion or if you use control
space it'll actually just show you all
the available options and you can scroll
through them with your mouse
so if you click the arrow one time we're
gonna get a little gif here and it's
gonna you know show you that there's a
few different things so i click control
space and it popped up all these
different things i can type
and then i started typing and allowed me
to auto complete it to title and i added
different parts to it
so as i'm literally typing this out it's
going to pop up both the help page as
well as the auto completion of that
so this works for yaml
and because we use yaml style syntax
inside code chunks and we'll talk about
that a little bit i also have the
ability to get this real-time
intelligence or feedback inside an
actual code chunk
so i can type out all these different
commands and again i'm not going to use
all 150 commands or whatever all the
time
but i remember i think there's something
about echo or if i can't remember what
it was about i can just type control
space and it will pop up this and allow
me to search through the available
options
so very very nice feature that was added
the other aspect and we talked about
you know switching from html to pdf with
uh the quarto document in our lovely
boston terriers cordo's getting much
much closer to this idea of true like
single source publishing
and how it accomplishes a lot of this i
mentioned that there's not latex or css
that i had to write manually i'm using
things like uh pandoc divs and pandox
spans
these allow me to write what are called
fenced div blocks and modify the
structure of the document across formats
the first example i have is using a css
class called dot big dash text and it
just makes the text really big 120
pixels
the part to focus on is that i have this
paragraph with big text and i'm putting
a fenced div around it
to write a fence div i use three colons
curly brackets and then apply the css
class to that
i type some text or something i want to
modify and then i close the fence by
adding an equal amount of the colons so
if there's three columns at the start i
have to close it with three colons at
the end
and that will generate something like
this a paragraph with big text that's
great i can also modify individual lines
of text or individual words with what is
called a span
so here i have this is text with special
formatting and around special i have a
square bracket on the left a square
bracket on the right and then i have
curly brackets and i'm applying an
inline css style of color equals red
and when i actually render this out i
get one single word with an entire
string that has been created as red text
now while i'm using css classes because
they're very easy to write and display
on the screen quarto bundles a lot of
embedded options that are applicable for
both pdf and for html and for word so
typically if you use the built-in quarto
and pandor divs you're going to get
things that are cross-format as much as
possible
so
again the way that you'd write out these
divs i want to make sure that we kind of
cover that is equal and matching uh
colons of the front and the start
you have to have at least three three is
what kind of gives it the initial kick
of like hey this is something special
treat it as a fence div so something
like colon colon colon and then some
content and then three more colons to
close it
but you're not limited to just three
you know i almost always write it with
three because that's the minimum but it
could be five or six or four or however
many you need
that's mostly important when you start
doing nesting of divs so i might have
four colons and then my curly brackets
dot columns and then i have two
name divs of column and column within it
that allows me to do off to the left and
off to the right
so this is something i'm using in the
slides i have today minimum and typical
is on the left column and any number can
be used is on the right column
but i can nest these together and allow
them to again apply across different
formats or across different presentation
types
now
again just reinforcing this idea of why
i would use
pandoctivs instead of just writing a
literal html div
is that you're not limited to just css
or html pandoc and quarto have
essentially named classes that apply
across formats so rather than writing
raw html you can have it apply to html
but also apply across other different
formats
so you can think of your kind of colon
colon colon or your fence div as an html
div but again it's applying in specific
situations to pdf or other formats it's
not just limited to an html format
uh
similarly with a span or this bracket
around a single word and then a
application of that class can be thought
of as pretty similar to like a literal
html span but again it's much more
transferable across formats um
you know for pandoc and for quarto and
all these different native attributes
i'm want to pause for one second there's
a great question for anyone that sees
this the rstudio cloud environment will
stay up for
forever i'm never going to close it down
and the workshop materials will also be
on on github so that you can access them
even outside of the our studio cloud
environment so you could download them
locally and use them as well a great
great question there
so
let's say that you know for that example
that i did with writing out my boston
terrier article using a fence div here
again starting with three colons then
the curly brackets i can do something
like layout number of columns equals two
and this will take two images and put
them each into one column and a second
column and allow me to figure set
what the images look like in my final
document it doesn't matter if it's word
or
pdf or html
that syntax will work across all of them
i can also add alt text or i'm saying
you know alt dash text here it's really
figure dash alt saying to apply what is
this image of it's an image of a male
boss interior and then i can go into
further detail for the actual image as
opposed to this toy example that we're
talking about
so embrace this idea of fence divs
because we're about to go really hard on
them for like 30 minutes because it's
what a lot of what cordo's providing
one of those first examples is the idea
of callout blocks so here i have again
my three colons curly brackets and the
class is called
a dot call out dash note
and this allows me to write different
types of notes that i'm embedding and
rendering inside my presentation but
again i can use these even in pdf where
i'm typically like more limited in how i
can style it
we've still embedded that so you can use
it across different formats
there's a lot of different call out
types so like notes and warnings or
important or caution basically allowing
you to say like here's a note it's
important but it's okay like it's green
it's not scary or this is red it's
really dangerous there's something i
really want you to to know about
and regardless of what the callout note
type is
you're going to use the similar syntax
fence div and then just change the dot
callout
last word so dash note or dash warning
or dash important or dash tip and you
can modify what it looks like without
having to customize the whole thing so
again it's like these helper functions
that allow you to do a lot of different
components together
with
these call out syntax you can also
collapse them so you can embed more
options than just one into a fence div
so not only is it a callout caution but
it's also collapsed so you can open it
and collapse it
to
show that inside html inside pdf or word
you don't have that interactivity so
it'll just ignore it but on an html page
it will embed that and allow you to
explore it
i have a whole lot of examples so in the
o2 authoring callout boxes you have the
ability to show these in both html and
in pdf just to prove that you can do
that and you can use them across formats
and you're not just limited to html
another really big one and this was one
that i always thought was uh exciting in
our markdown was tab sets or this
ability to have you know ability to
click through multiple tabs
so tap sets follow the almost exact same
idea you have your fence div and the
class now is dot panel dash tab set
and you can have
different components within it
the other aspect of tap sets is that
you're going to give them each a title
so i'm going to use
a level 2 header or
pound pound and then some text to say
this is the header and what i want to
call it out as the different sections
so i can have this
one that has like code and it's
evaluating you know head of empty cars
and then has the actual output in a
separate tab and i can move back and
forth through them
and again it's a tab set so i can have
this dot panel tab set as the class of
my fence div
and then i have code and output within
that
there are some good questions about
these fence divs and translating them to
other languages
again the syntax up here is going to be
written in english so that part is not
language specific it's it's it is tied
to english i'd have to check with the
team about some of the localization
efforts because they are doing a lot for
trying to make localization work really
well in cordo
but again inside the body of the
document or inside the body of the div
you can do whatever you want so that
could be whatever language you wanted to
do both in the actual written word as
well as it's not limited to just r you
could make that python or bash or julia
or other different things
so i only have two tabs if we go back
but it could be as many tabs fit on the
page and you can go really crazy with it
you just want to make sure to separate
each of them with these level two
headers
now the most important part i thought
about fence divs is using them for
figure layout because again i i very
much want to align images and graphics
and often i might be bringing in like
different graphics and wanting to
arrange them on my layout of my my
document
there's a couple different ways of doing
this and i'm highlighting three of them
so again these are fence divs so you
have three colons and then a curly
bracket and then i have something like
layout number of columns equals two or
layout number of rows equals three so
you can think about your document as how
many columns do i want and the images
will fit into those columns or how many
rows do i want and then the images will
fit into those rows both work and maybe
you just have more images and you want
to structure it that way
alternatively you can use the bracket
bracket syntax to define literal like
percentages
so i have a document with three images
for example i want the first image to
take up seventy percent of the page the
second image take up thirty percent of
the page and then on a new line take up
one hundred percent of the page
and that will
allow me to create um you know very
specific type setting for all the three
images there
i can also use negative values to inject
white space so again i'm adding up to
essentially like a hundred percent here
but it's forty percent on image one a
blank space of negative 20 and then 40
percent for image two
new line because i'm closing my initial
bracket and opening up a new one and
then i have a hundred percent for my
last image on the bottom
and again this will apply across formats
so like just like tab sets can be used
inside this presentation and that's how
i created them today
i can also use those figure layouts to
control things on a presentation or a
pdf or html page
because websites and presentations are
formatted differently it's not a fact of
they will or won't work but often
you're limited because you're switching
from landscape to portrait mode so i
would think of a lot of these is really
powerful for portrait mode in terms like
pdf word html like those are really good
ways of using this as opposed to a
presentation you're really limiting
yourself probably to just like two
images side by side or columns as
opposed to more complex layouts you want
to do
so for a first example of what this
would actually look like we have layout
and again we're using that forty percent
minus twenty percent of negative space
forty percent for the second image and
then a hundred percent on the bottom
and then create something like this
inside of whatever pdf or word or html
document you're creating and you can
actually have you know some blank space
and then fitting the images
automatically into the remaining area
so you can have a nicely structured
document and shrink images automatically
or expand them automatically to fit the
size of it just by controlling their
percentages
and again all those like number of
columns or number of rows would also
work but just the layout equals allows
us to be the most specific about how we
want to structure the document so that's
where i wanted to spend the most time
now that was a lot about
fence divs let's also bring in some of
these spans and give them a little bit
of love too so fence divs typically
apply across like a whole paragraph or a
bunch of different images or like a
whole big section of the page
spans are applied to very specific words
so i might have a word within a
paragraph that i'm applying some type of
class to
so maybe i have something like a
footnote and here it says like a literal
maybe a footnote and it has a number one
beside it
i created that with the footnote itself
so the footnotes way of doing it is a
upwards bracket or upwards tilde and
then a bracket around some text and that
will inject a footnote forward so it's
kind of like a first span that we're
looking at
or i might have some magically appearing
words with an additional point after
so if we click through one time two time
and then three time different portions
of the sentence will pop up as i click
through the presentation
if i click one more time i'll actually
see the actual code to generate that
so i've applied a square bracket around
two words and then my curly brackets and
a class in this case a dot fragment
which allows it to appear
as a delayed part of just within that
whole sentence and then i can put
another fragment immediately after it
and basically build up an entire
sentence as well as building up the page
itself
and that will work inside your different
format presentations
there's a couple questions about
cordo and working inside
our studio
unfortunately i won't be able to kind of
go through all the different ways across
different
environments so in some very specific
windows environments you'd have to use
rstudio or sorry
cordo.command
to execute it um as opposed to quarto
so if we go trying to think if
there's a good link and i'll share it
afterwards um inside our studio
community where we troubleshooted with
one customer
um
or not customer
someone in the community about how to
troubleshoot through using cordo on
windows when they did a separate
installation and having to name space it
with cordo.command
if you want to use our studio cloud we
could always hop back over to that real
briefly and just show uh rachel that
link
yep i can um share that now and i can
also go find the
community
link as well i'm gonna paste the link to
our studio cloud again if you just want
to get started and try some of these
things out you can use rstudio cloud and
then you don't have to install or
configure anything
but
if you need to use it locally you again
want to make sure that you're on the
latest version of our studio so
2022.07.1
and that's also linked to on the front
page of the webinar so if you go
to this next link that i'm sharing in
the chat
and i put it into the chat and it's also
displayed on the screen if you go there
it'll guide you through downloading and
installing uh rstudio
but again using our studio cloud like
rachel's doing right now she could
actually run all the different quarto
commands and rendering and it will be
available and ready to go
um
let's hop back into the slides
all right so we
basically talked about these fence divs
that they're kind of like
these elements that apply to a whole
section or whole block of text or
paragraph that you're applying it to
and then spans as a way to apply
specific classes to individual items
so you can like change the
just a small word as opposed to a whole
paragraph together
the last half we're going to talk a bit
more about code so in terms of yes you
can do all this layout with just
markdown
but you can apply it to specific code
and how it's applied as well
so great question here from jeff
so can engines
point to specific python installs for
condo environments
so yes you can choose specific engines
so if you don't specify an engine chordo
will just say like whatever language is
found first like r or python it'll
default to just whatever version of r
you have or a default jupiter kernel
that's available
you can also click through and choose a
very specific kernel so you could say
just use jupyter and it will find
whatever python version is on your path
or maybe you want to use python 3 and
force that you can say a specific python
version or you can go all the way down
to using a very specific um
kernel and both naming it giving like a
virtual environment is what i use this a
lot for is like i've created a project
specific virtual environment and i can
have that be forced to use rather than
just whatever the default is as i'm
moving between projects
so you can choose the engine and again
this is part of the beauty of quarto is
you're not just limited to whatever the
default is but you can have a bit more
control over choosing how it's executed
so let's move on to the next slide for
knitter code cells specifically and for
code cells in general there's a lot of
different options and you know i don't
expect y'all to memorize all of those
again if you use
the command or sorry the control space
syntax inside of a code chunk it will
allow you to see what is available and
then there's auto completion if you're
using the latest version of our studio
along with cordo together
i'm going to talk a little bit about
what a code chunk looks like especially
because they're a little bit different
than what you might have experienced
with our markdown
if we think about a code chunk inside a
quarto markdown document it's going to
again have this idea of like three back
ticks on either end so backtick back to
backtick and then you're saying what is
the engine with curly brackets so that'd
be like r or python or bash or whatever
language you want it to execute
and then you're gonna be placing options
underneath that which what is called the
hash pipe uh syntax
and that'll follow something like hash
pipe option one colon space value and
you can define things like the label is
equal to car cylinder and i want to echo
the code false i don't want it to show
the code that i'm displaying
so by putting them inside this hash pipe
or what is called like a yaml syntax
that's where you get the auto completion
and the ability to kind of search
through all the features that are
available
so a more complex
document might look something like this
in terms of i have a label i have
echoing i have an output location of
column and you know labels equal to
figure quality a caption and warning
goes false
so these might be familiar to you from
your time in our markdown
but we're going to be putting them
inside with this hash pipe or yaml style
syntax as opposed to putting them all
into the language engine that's at the
top
but again we get the same code output in
terms of we still create a graphic and
our r code is the same and we're using
the knitter code chunk options in this
way
again this works for python 2 so you're
going to use the same syntax with the
jupyter engine as well as the knitter
engine
and you can choose a
label and a figure caption
as well as like evaluating it and saying
evalue equals true or eval equals false
so regardless of what your way doing it
you can choose kind of how you want to
display or modify the code
now for creating code chunks you could
always manually type them out again like
back tick back to backtick curly bracket
the engine curly bracket and then
closing
the code chunk
but in both vs code and inside rstudio
you have keyboard shortcuts so something
like control alt i or command option i
allows you to insert a code chunk
automatically
the add chunk command is also available
in the visual editor mode of our studio
so you can actually just like click
into that and add it via the visual
editor
button or just via the tab bar inside
the quarto document or you can use the
shortcut or manually type it out
one of my favorite ways of doing this
though is using the command palette this
is something that's a bit newer to our
studio and when i say newer it's about
two years old i think but a lot of
people it's still new to them
if you do command shift p or control
shift p
inside
our studio or inside vs code it will pop
up a area where you can search for
commands so you could type command shift
p
insert code chunk and it would
automatically like pull that up as an
option to insert
so again whatever code chunk you're
doing it's going to default to what's
available inside already so if you've
been using r it's going to automatically
insert r but if you were using say julia
or python code chunks uh they would
default to using python or julia code
chunks
julia would be
julian python would be executed by the
jupiter engine and
r would be executed by the knitter
engine
again there's a lot of code chunks if
you want to look at all of them you can
look through yeway's chunk options at
ua.org knitteroptions or at quarter.org
we have all the options available for r
and python and julia for the different
formats that are available
if you've used our markdown before you
may have been surprised by the syntax
that we just showed or showing the hash
pipe syntax you might be more familiar
with putting them into
uh like the chunk label or the option
equals true inside the actual fence
portion or the curly brackets at the top
so while this can still be executed by
cordo and it's backwards compatible
we get those features of like auto
completion and full compatibility across
languages and across formats by putting
them into the hash pipe syntax
so in this literal presentation i'm
executing this code and it's getting me
the echo equals fence the knee valve
goes true
but we'd prefer to do the um
evaluation that we see here on the page
in terms of using the hash pipe syntax
as opposed to
the previous syntax that was all
squished inside uh the the chunk label
section
so again backwards compatible with our
markdown but let we're going to try and
move towards this hash pipe syntax with
putting them into the body of the code
chunk itself
we can call it kind of colloquially the
hash pipe if you've ever heard weezer's
song called hash pipe that's how i
always remember it but it's also like a
pound sign in a vertical line and then
after that you can start typing your
chunk options within it
for people that might be wondering why
do you have this in terms of you know
can i use this with different code
chunks it'll work with all your
different code chunks so like r python
sql bash whatever you're doing those can
be used with this syntax so there's
consistency across the engine whether
using jupiter or knitter or evaluating
different types of code it's consistent
across them
it also means that the chunk options are
fully
kind of consistent with the yaml so
there's the ability to define things in
the yaml at the top or in the chunk
options and this allows you to kind of
hopefully have like less mental burden
because you're sharing syntax across the
yaml header and the metadata as well as
the chunk options
and then something that's kind of much
more in your face that's a benefit is
you have this control over the order
spacing of chunk options you're not just
limited to one
long line but you can actually do things
across their own individual lines
so on this next page where we have all
the quarter chunk options
if we click the arrow one more time it's
going to highlight lines three through
eight
you can see that we have each chunk
option is on its own line so warning
goes false figure caption is air quality
figure align is left and then for the
alt text i was actually able to
set a multi-line figure alternative text
and not have to have it run off the page
so i put in another vertical line and
then i was able to type out this long
string and separate it out into multiple
lines without having to be all clumped
together
you can still have setup chunks and you
can still use like ops chunk set if
you're familiar with that syntax and you
can also do some of that by the yaml and
there's an execute option inside the
yaml to set kind of global things for
your document
overall another one that people often
ask about and if we click the arrow one
more time is how do i evaluate literal r
code inside of a chunk
so you might have something like
gluing or pasting together a string and
saying like what is some value
so by using the exclamation expression
uh syntax i can then evaluate literal r
code within a chunk option and paste it
together so i can do something like
creating a figure caption that is based
off the data itself and taking the mean
of air quality and also rounding it so
it's a bit nicer looking
without having to do that outside of the
code chunk so i can embed literal r code
together
another good question so rachel if we
click back one time
you can see that all of the chunk
options are now displayed code line
numbers allows me to intermittently
highlight inside reveal.js or this
presentation specific lines of code
so if you look on line three if i click
the right arrow button it will
fade everything else and highlight line
three
so that allows me to again have a bit
more consistency around like oh i want
to show this line of code and i can't
even control the presentation like
rachel's helping me out so i can have it
navigate to that section even though i'm
not even running the presentation myself
as far as the next question that
typically arises i have our markdown
documents and i want to render them as
is to cordo i was like what all do i
have to change do i have to change a lot
of things rachel did you have a question
sorry
i noticed there was a question that's
been asked a few times so i just wanted
to ask it um is there a shortcut for the
hash pipe
uh i
don't think there is but if you if you
type one hash pipe and click enter it
will automatically add those below them
so basically once you've inserted one
hash pipe as you go to more chunk
options it will automatically insert
the
basically the starting structure of the
pound sign the vertical line and a space
for you thank you for that question
rachel awesome thanks
perfect
so for people that say like i have a
bunch of our markdown documents i want
to um
i want to apply it across different
things or i want to convert them over to
porto um you can generally just
render them via the command line so you
can call quarto render on a document and
render it and force it to be used via
quarto
if you wanted to modify your yaml and
make it quarto specific
you could change two primary parts you
change output to format
and something like html document to html
there are smaller things of things like
number underscore sections rather than
using that syntax uh we're using pandoc
style or traditional yaml style with a
dash
but overall you can see that like as
you're moving between these documents
that the formats actually look very
similar
and again you don't have to convert all
of your documents over it's more of like
keep the existing documents you have use
something like the quarto r package or
the quarto command line tool
to render older markdown documents and
then write new documents via cordo
but if you wanted to convert your
documents and change all the yaml you
could do it manually as well if you'd
like to
this is partially off the page i'm sorry
about that but uh for the yammel for
quarto the big important part here is
again
quarto is going to have this like word
dash word syntax like if we think of
number dash sections on line five under
quarta
as opposed to our markdown is using an
underscore for a lot of different things
so you if you want to be more consistent
that dash syntax is what we're looking
for
a couple good questions about rendering
like a parent qmd that has our markdown
files as its children
that's a pretty specific thing in terms
of your bringing in code from an our
markdown file if you're just reading in
the lines of code that's fine because
you're not actually rendering it to our
markdown you're rendering it to quarto
but if you have let's say like a quarto
project or a choreo website
anything that's dot rmd within that will
actually be rendered via quarto so you
can't like render something to
our markdown
just like out of the box via quarto it's
going to be a quarto document at that
point it's just going to try its best to
convert it over
good question
within the workshop material i have what
is called like an old or markdown again
without changing anything i can render
it to quarto by using the quarto command
line interface or the quarto r package
or i could manually go in and change dot
rmd to dot qmd and that indicates hey
use quarto or i could change the format
from output to format to convert it over
via the yaml header itself
now as far as this conversion process
well again it's not required and many
times you can kind of render something
as is
option one is i want an r markdown i
want to always use chordo for the
rendering change just dot rmd.qmd
that tells our studio and that tells
cordo this is a quarto document
render it as quarto so it'll force it to
be executed as a quarto document no
matter what is in the ammo
option two is you can manually change
the output
like output equals html document to
something like format equals html and
again this will force using quarto even
if the extension is dot rmd
the last option though here is you know
you've got a red during the quarto but
maybe your uh
knitter chunks your code chunks are
different
so there is a function in the dev
version of knitter as of a couple days
ago that allows you to take
syntax like fig dot width equals one i
think rates you have to click through
twice on that sorry
one more time there you go so fig dot
width equals one and it'll convert it
over to the hash pipe syntax so that'll
allow you to take an entire document and
very quickly convert all of the knitter
syntax over to the newer syntax
i wouldn't necessarily use this like all
the time i'd rather just write them as
they're supposed to be
moving forward but if you have older
documents this would allow you to
convert the chunk header into the hash
pipe syntax
again you don't have to convert
everything you it's backward compatible
with the older chunk options
but if you want to be consistent or you
want to kind of move towards the syntax
that allows you to be more consistent
moving forward
the other part was uh you know we talked
quite a bit about this fence div or
these pandoc divs and something like the
colon colon colon curly brackets layout
or layout number of rows or number of
columns
again we're getting consistency here
between something you can do in markdown
as well as something you can do with
code
so if we click through this
twice
we're going to have
the code and then we're going to
highlight line four
layout number of column equals 2 is the
exact same syntax i use for fence divs
to typeset images
but now i'm using it for
generated graphics and r
so i can get side by side images
obviously on this presentation because
it's in uh
horizontal landscape mode they're kind
of running off the page
but
on a larger document or a more
traditional portrait page i would have
two side-by-side images and the layout
structure will look nice there
i can also use the
on line 7 if i click through one more
time here i get layout and i have that
again percentage style so now i have
forty percent for image one forty
percent for image two
and negative twenty percent of blank
space in the middle
and when i do this
it's generating again two graphics with
blank space in the middle and also
applying the figure caption and the
labeling of those in my entire document
so a nice ability to again have
consistent syntax of typesetting
arranging your documents whether it's
bringing in raw graphics off disk or
generating graphics on the fly in r or
python or julia
the last part that we're going to be
covering today or kind of a less focus
is more about aesthetics in terms of you
probably have strong opinions about what
your your
things you're creating should look like
i really like the defaults in cordo
they're really good they generally
follow
nice examples of like
contrast for accessibility but perhaps
you just have a very strong opinion
about what the overall document should
look like
so number one for things like html uh
quarters html is styled with bootstrap 5
and has these opinionated defaults so
bootstrap is a popular css framework
very common for responsive websites and
version 5 is the latest version of this
quarto comes pre-installed with 25
themes from bootswatch which is
applications of bootstrap across
different themes
and you can
go into html call theme and then choose
a format like litera or something else
to um
change the different format to something
else you want to see
so litera is one that i really really
like that's what i use for my personal
blog it's nice and has
a overall
good good section of like this is what's
available
you can also use a specific theme and
further customize components with scss
or sas
so maybe you really like leterra but you
want to change a few small components
you can do that with custom.css files
to modify specific components and use
everything else
uh for the question rachel let me see i
can get a direct link to
this
so if we do authoring i'm going to paste
a new link into the chat
so that's the direct link to the slide
i'm on right or the slide deck on right
now
and then because i'm using reveal js if
you go there
you can actually click at the bottom
left and it'll open up
the
section where there's a lot of different
slides you can move towards there's a
hamburger menu at the bottom left of the
of the page
three three vertical or horizontal lines
and that will allow you to move quickly
to the aesthetics
portion so we're on slide 45 right now
thanks rachel
um as far as the bootswatch themes um
those in action would look something
like what i'm displaying here on the
screen so if we move through these we
have a basic blog with something like
lotera that's very minimalistic and very
high contrast
you could switch over to something
that's like in a dark mode that has
primarily like a dark blue background
with a lighter gray or white text in
front or this really nicely themed kind
of lavender or light purple and again
all of the components are changing in
unison so whether you're doing a blog or
even just an individual html page
all these components will be changed
automatically you have nice
you know visualizations as well as the
nice theming of your blog itself
i included a section underneath o4
static for bootswatch themes and again
link out to a lot of the different
available themes so html themes from
cordo.org and all this stuff that's
available there
for presentations for today thanks to
rachel's help we've been doing working
through kind of a unison reveal.js
presentation so rachel's been driving it
and i created it initially and you're
able to create these pretty easily with
with just a little bit of code
so a very basic reveal.js presentation
would look something like this and have
a title my first presentation the format
is equal to reveal js and then i create
new slides by creating uh level two
headers so like slide one slide two
slide 3 here on the page
each of which has
2 pound signs indicating a level 2
header
within those i have a few different
lists so i have like lists for content
and content
i have an image i'm bringing in and i
can even display code so all the
presentation you've seen today over the
past about two hours has been covering
porto by creating a quarto presentation
with cordo so very very meta but a nice
way of displaying code and talking about
code with with graphics as well as
programmatically creating uh
presentations
um important parts to note here is that
you're going to create new slides with
level one or level two headers so that'd
be like pound pound heading and then you
can add content or list or images or
codes within each of those pages and
just fit them into whatever the overall
structure of your page looks like
again if we use our fence divs we can
use that to create columns so i might
have some content on the left more
content an additional list and a
paragraph of text that is important to
hold on the left but it's fun to include
below the list
and on the right i have a nice picture
of howard who is like he always is just
sleeping with his head smushed up
against the left side of the page
but by using these columns i can overall
structure my document and put them side
by side
that basic syntax if i'm putting it
together and kind of deleting some of
the text
i'm again using fenced div syntax so i
have four colons because i'm going to
nest two
fence divs within it so four colons and
then a dot columns with an s
and then within it each different column
i'm creating i'm just creating two here
will be its own fence div with a dot
column class
and then an additional dot fragment so
they show up as i move through the
presentation
and then i have my image and again
including some alt text of a picture of
my dog howard sleeping with his head
smooshed against the side of the table
but again you can put it together this
and without having to manually align
with html you can just use quarto syntax
to create your presentation
that's all i'm covering our
presentations for today because we are
going to have another workshop going
over presentations alone later on
because you can do more than just html
although i really like
reveal.js presentations
the last part we're going to cover for
today in total will be quarto projects
and again don't forget to
come to isabella velasquez's
presentation she's going to be coming
and talking to us at the end of august
august 30th to talk about quarter
projects and building your own blog with
cordo and i can almost guarantee you
that you can have some type of working
blog created in under an hour
so quarto projects number one are
directories that provide a way to render
all or some of the files in a directory
with a single command something like
quarto render my project
um another one might be a way to share
yaml configuration across multiple
documents in terms of rather than
writing a bunch of yaml for individual
documents over and over i can use a
quarto project to apply the same yaml to
an entire directory of you know five or
ten or even dozens or hundreds of
documents
it also allows me to control where
documents are rendered to so i can
redirect my artifacts out to a separate
directory and have a clean directory of
experimentation and then the actual
final output to a separate directory
and most importantly i think for things
like blogs or other complex sites is i
can freeze rendered output so you can
imagine that i have a blog post
from four years ago using some code with
a package that may not even exist
anymore
rather than having to re-execute that
four-year-old blog post every time i
render my my blog or my website it'll
actually store the computation and
freeze that output for me so when i
render everything else it just renders
the new thing or the things i'm telling
it to render
and in addition projects allow you to
create essentially aggregations so you
can imagine a book or a website is
really just multiple quarter documents
or html pages or pdf pages that are
combined into a single output so just
like the website for accessing the
content you found today or a book or
anything else you're publishing
you can create much more complex things
by using quarter projects
for what a quarter project looks like
you might have a minimal one that looks
something like this
it's always going to be created with a
underscorecordo.yaml file that is always
what the file is called to create a
quarto project
underscorecordo.yaml
and that will affect everything in its
directory and subdirectories of it
so for number one within the
quarter.yaml it's a project and we're
not saying it's a website or it's a book
we're just saying this is a quarto
project and i want you to take
everything i create and throw them into
this underscore output folder
and i can apply some yaml across all of
them i want table of contents to always
be true on a number sections and i have
a bibliography that i want to bring in
for all of my citations
then i can also say that i'm creating
these in both html and pdf at the same
time
so for my html i can apply custom
styling with css and use a specific math
method and then for pdf i want to create
a report and customize the overall
layout
so it allows you to kind of structure
all these different things create a new
output directory with all the files that
you're rendering and it could again be
many many files and control it for
different syntaxes in html and pdf
again
we're about three minutes away from
being two hours i'm going to stick
around for quite a while to answer
questions thank you for all the great
questions
but if you want to learn how to build a
blog or really create like a complex
quarter project make sure to come and
join us for isabelle of alaska's
presentation
august 30th at 12 p.m eastern you can
add that to your calendar as a reminder
with rstd dot io slash quarto dash blog
and that will allow you to be reminded
you know a couple weeks from now that
hey this presentation is happening again
it'll be on youtube and it'll be
recorded and live streamed for your
viewing pleasure
as we kind of wrap up for today on the
actual presentation and get more into q
a and answering a lot of the good
questions you'll have
i want to give a huge shout out to the
entire quarto development team cordo is
really a labor of love and crafted with
love and care
by the team so development of cordo is
sponsored by our studio pbc soon to be
posit pvc
the same core team works on both cordo
and our markdown so you shouldn't be
afraid about some of these changes you
should be excited names like yiway jj
lair kristoff charles carlos similar
people that are working or the same
people working on both cordo and our
markdown and knitter
beyond that because it's an open source
project there's also a sub link out to
all of the contributors and all the
people who've contributed to it you can
contribute in ways like bug reports or
feature requests or feedback in general
and you can get that done at github.com
slash quarto dash dev slash quarto dash
cli
to close in terms of the presentation
don't worry about going away i'll answer
more questions and share some more
things why you should consider cordo
batteries included with this shared
syntax across output types in different
languages you have the ability to choose
your own editor and your preferred data
science language we will be doing a
workshop or kind of a webinar on using
jupiter and vs code in python with cordo
and doing that as a separate webinar so
we can dedicate there's enough time to
it
and that our markdown's still going to
be maintained but we're building all
these new features into cordo so our
markdown has a huge ecosystem that we're
still supporting and still maintaining
but we're adding in new features into
quarto so they apply to everyone as
opposed to building out individual or
markdown extension packages
if you want to access the materials i
have full workshop materials from two
days that we used at our studio conf i
have the webinar slides that are linked
to here as well as the rstudio cloud
content all of which is available in the
um
on the youtube page as well
if you have follow-up questions i'm
going to do my best to stick around for
a while and answer some of those i know
that some of y'all two hours is a big
commitment so maybe we'll see you later
if you have questions you can ask them
on community.studio.com
underneath the cordo tag
or again i'll stick around for a little
bit today or reach out anytime on
twitter
with that i'm going to bring rachel back
on screen
we can drop the presentation and we can
go back to the talking head format and
the exciting kind of rachel and tom show
as we talk about the morning and quarto
itself
thank you so much tom that was awesome
and
so impressed with you just running
through with our screen share not
working immediately that went very
smoothly after the fact
awesome rachel thank you so much for the
quick adaptation and for being a good
colleague running through it all um
there are a lot of questions i know so
many questions yes
i want to make sure to go over to slido
first to ask some of the anonymous
questions too
um somebody had asked and it's been
upvoted quite a bit
is it possible to add authentication to
a cordo website
yeah
so it's a great question there's a
couple different ways you can think
about it
cordo if you're generating a website is
just.html or it's just general html
content you can publish it wherever you
want
um obviously like with things like
rstudio connect you can publish cordo
like to your own server or behind your
own firewall and control both the
rendering process and the authentication
process
for some people though they're like well
i'm an individual like i can't buy and
stand up connect and that's totally fine
um one other option is netlify has an
authenticated
level i think at like 19 a month
and you can add authentication to
specific pages and host your content on
netlify
um outside of that again because cordo
is generating like literal html anywhere
that you can generally embed html and
add-on authentication could also be done
there so you're not
you're not kind of limited it's just
anywhere you can host a website and that
authentication you can also do that via
quarter
awesome thank you
i was teasing tom that i feel like this
is a morning talk show that we're on
right here
um so another question that was upvoted
was from kyle and it was
for collaborative projects with r and
python is there a recommended method for
tracking packaged versions
would rms gather this kind of situation
yeah
very good questions so if you go to
cordo.org and i'll grab a link for
rachel to share on the screen here in a
second
there's an entire section dedicated to
essentially that topic and that's really
what cordo's trying to provide
is a way of allowing colleagues in
multiple languages to work together in
the same project and not bump up into
each other when they're trying to
execute their code
so that's part of what projects and
managing execution allow you to do
so i'm going to drop a link into the
chat that is addressing this directly
and then rachel if you want to screen
share through that
real briefly we'll talk about what it
means oh yes i will screen share sorry
sometimes it doesn't let me uh grab the
link from there if you want to just send
it in the private chat
absolutely
there it is
um and what this this whole section
covers is essentially that idea of i
want to freeze or control execution and
you can do that with or without uh
virtual environments
so we're going to put a side by side
real quick so on this page it talks
about just the general idea of managing
execution so if you scroll down to
freeze
you can use freeze to basically say
i want you to freeze the output of code
meaning that even if someone else tries
to render it it's not going to
re-execute the code they don't even have
to have python installed on their
machine or are installed on their
machine
it's just going to be rendering the html
or the pdf via quarto
if you have freeze equals false then it
will always try and re-execute code but
freeze equals true or freeze equals auto
allows you to say only re-execute code
when i change the source code or just
never do it unless i manually force
click render on that document
if you go down uh one section lower
there's using freeze and then one more
subsection virtual environments
it talks about that you might have like
a requirements.txt or a virtual
environment like a vm in python or an rn
in r
again we're not doing a special language
it's whatever you're using in that other
language is what you use so i most
commonly use
vm in
virtual in python and i'm using rnv and
r to control
exactly installation installing specific
libraries or a collection of libraries
and defining those into a virtual
environment
great question thank you
um i see over on youtube
jake hi jake had just asked do packages
like sharing gun themer work with cordo
another good question so i would
generally say
so sharingan is
let's start from the top sharingan
actually uses a library called remark.js
as the way of building slides
porto decided to move to reveal.js
the reason why we made that distinction
is reveal.js is pandoc compatible
so you can actually edit
presentations in visual mode and get
these syntax and like the highlighting
to work properly
uh kudos to rachel for getting both
femur and sherengan correct that's
awesome high five
and i was just asking who said that the
correct way because i don't know you
sounded more confident
no you you got exactly right but i would
say so sherrington themer out of the box
is not necessarily going to work with
cordo
but the same ideas will so you can
imagine that
remark.js which powers sherengin there's
specific css components that affect
specific parts
so you can use um
you can use themes and quarto bundles a
bunch of different themes for reveal.js
presentations i would start there
and then there's a whole subsection on
theming or
applying html formatting to your themes
so if you go to quarter.org reveal.js
reveal themes it'll talk about that
good question awesome um i'll take
another question over from
youtube
and
this was one that was
from a bit earlier
but was how does cordo handle two
pictures in the same slide
or bullet breakdowns and icons
yep
so if you had a presentation like i had
in reveal js
the images are going to be stacked on
top of each other you know it's not
going to try and align them
automatically it's just going to pull
them to the left and inject them one on
top of the other
you can use something like the dot
columns fence divs to put them side by
side almost like rachel and i are left
aligned and right aligned right now in
two columns
or you could use um
absolute positioning with graphics and
you could do a dot absolute class and
then say literally from the top or the
left or the right or the bottom of the
screen
put them 150 pixels to the left and 200
pixels up
um i would probably not put them inside
bullets unless you had really small
images
you could do icons with like font
awesome if they're really small
but generally i would rely on alignment
with the more typical fence divs that we
showed in today's presentation
great thank you i see there was actually
a question on slido that covered that as
well
with regards to scientific papers too
perfect
yeah as much as possible using the
quarto fence div syntax means you can
use it anywhere now there's places where
if you try and do five images on one
page in a presentation it might be a bit
awkward because you can't scroll uh
vertically
but on a academic article or a website
it makes a lot of sense because you're
scrolling up and down and able to move
between images
over a few questions from the slido over
to the the chat so it may look like i'm
asking them here but
is how do r and python share objects if
they're all in one quarter document
yep so if you're trying to mix and match
r and python in the same single qmd
then you're using reticulate you're
basically saying i'm okay with using
them together so i have an r
installation and i have a python
installation and i'm using reticulate to
pass objects back and forth
there's also the idea of like in uh in
python land there's things i believe
like python 2r or other kind of
libraries like that i'm not as deeply
familiar with them but i'm very familiar
and comfortable with using reticulate
inside cordo
the alternative is within a quarto
project you could have a native python
document
that someone's editing on a whole
different computer like we were talking
about earlier and an r document that i'm
editing on my computer and we can still
collaborate by using freeze equals true
and we're passing just data back and
forth like
she rachel works on a python document
writes out a parquet file that i then
ingest into r and work on in a separate
document
that's totally possible as well where
you don't have to mix and match them in
the same document but in the same
project
great thank you and there are so many
great questions here today too so we
will make sure that we answer them in
some format like a blog post and put
that on the community that our
studio.com site too
um
maybe do a couple more and then we'll
move over to the the blog post i know uh
i don't wanna keep you too long and
we're already two hours and ten but i'm
having a good time but i wanna make sure
we'll probably be here okay
that's good let's say well maybe we'll
do three more is that okay
okay can we add sql script in quarto
absolutely so knitter actually allows
you to execute um sql code in a knitter
code chunk
so rather than using r as the when
you're doing your brackets it would be
like back tick back take backtick curly
bracket sql and you could write raw sql
code
or you could use something like um
dbplier in r to write a sql code via
dplyr and it'll actually do the
conversion for you
and i believe in python there's a couple
libraries like sql alchemy that allow
you to write a python code
that executes actually a sql as well
perfect
you put a lot of pressure to pick a few
questions here there's a lot of
questions let's make it five there you
go we'll go to we'll go to 120 how about
that let's i'm going to go by some of
the top voted ones that are on
slido so i don't have to make the
decision
um but somebody had asked and let me
copy it over here
uh what are
some of the advantages of using cordo
over emacs
org mode
you can read it there
absolutely yeah so
there's a lot of different ways of
taking a document with literate
programming you know part of that is
like you have things like jupiter and mb
convert you have jupiter and nbdev you
have cordo you have our markdown you
have raw pandoc
um
you have org mode which is a actually an
extension to emacs where like in your
like terminal inside emacs rather than
an editor you can write documents with
literate programming
rather than saying what the advantage is
is kind of making it a
language and
location agnostic
whereas emacs and org mode kind of says
you're
basically saying like you're going to
work inside that format only
quarto is really just plain text so you
could use it in any text editor you
could use it without a text editor and
just use it inside a terminal if you
really wanted to
you can use it like really richly inside
our studio and vs code and inside
jupiter and you're meeting people where
they are as opposed to saying like this
is the
uh only way to do it it's like you're
allowing different editors in different
languages to meet in the middle
i will say though that like i'm not
deeply familiar with org mode
as a user but i'm aware of like there
are other things out there that are
great and get you know things done and
just calling out a few of those
thank you
um another upvoted question on slido was
how do we comment a line in yaml
yeah so if you
i would typically say i don't add like
uh commenting to yaml code in terms of
like i'm always a bit nervous about
messing things up
you can do a pound sign in front of
specific lines and that at least in
quarto appears to comment out that line
and it no longer executes but more
typically like
if you're trying to say like i'm doing
the specific thing and like writing out
a description like literate program of
yaml you might actually just want to put
that into a comment below the gamble
like you can do an html comment or a
hidden code chunk that doesn't display
when you render the document but it says
this is why i'm using this yaml option
as opposed to trying to constrain
yourself to figuring out a way of doing
commenting in the yaml chunk itself
awesome
um one other question from slido was
i have a blog based on blog down
should i be creating new blog posts in
cordo
so what i will say is you should ask
yourself and this is a deep
introspective question do i love hugo or
do i not love hugo
hugo is the rendering engine that blog
down uses so when you're actually using
blog down you're writing dot rmds or dot
our markdown files that generate md
files and then you hand over everything
to hugo to render it and create html
that is really powerful for creating
exceptionally complex and specific
websites um i could think of some of the
websites i've seen that like people like
allison hill has created that are just
beautiful and very functional and
amazing
i am a noted hugo non-fan whatever the
opposite of a stan is i am not a stan of
hugo
it's a separate thing that i have to
manage uh the block down team has done a
lot of work to make it much more user
friendly
but for me it just was not the right
option like it was not something i loved
if you have a very complex workflow and
block downs working for you again we're
going to maintain blog down and you can
technically write
hugo style markdown documents with cordo
some of the things you lose by
using hugo as your rendering engine
is things like interactivity
because you're only writing out that md
that then gets parsed by hugo is you're
always going to be limited in the things
you can do with html widgets or jupyter
widgets or observable because you're
writing like plain text
um but blog down is very very efficient
at rendering like a thousand blog posts
and i know for some people like yiway he
literally has a blog that's been going
for 15 years and has thousands of blog
posts
for him the the conversion cost is it
doesn't make any sense like his blog is
working great we're maintaining block
down he's actually the maintainer of
blog down so he knows it's not going
away
so you don't have to but i personally
switched over to using uh
quarto blogs from distill so if you're
coming from the distilled land i would
say there's a much stronger emphasis
that cordo brings a lot to the table
that you're familiar with with distill
but does it better
long question
no one answered sorry
okay two more questions i see cairo had
asked on youtube yeah youtube live is it
possible to mix text and image content
in the layout div
so you can there is a section of the
page
authoring
[Music]
figures
block layout
and i'm going to type this in and paste
it here into the chat if you want to
highlight it
kind of
you can there are certain times when
things are a bit more surprising than
i'd like in terms of like if i'm trying
to mix text and images in a table that's
still something that cordo's working on
for
making it a really good experience
but with the general block layout
syntax which is very similar to like
layout number of columns equals two
you can mix and match some text some
paragraph lists and graphics together
but still some more work for us to do to
make that really really really good
great thank you
and i also see brian had asked can we
write package vignettes as porto
yeah so um
it's kind of a dependency with cran so
cran is expecting
like dot md and rmd files
um if you were to create a vignette
um you'd really be rendering out to
specific flavor of pdf
i don't believe
off the top of my head that that's ready
to go right now
edgar ruiz part of the team here at our
studio is working on a package called
eco down which allows you to write
essentially like complex websites that
encompass multiple packages with cordo
and using that kind of as an extension
of more of package down
i'll have to look at specifically for
package vignettes as pdf via quarto but
again you're not really getting
like the thing you're doing is you're
building for crayon as opposed to
building for anyone and because there's
limitations and a focus on what cran
accepts
all the things you can do in cordo are
not necessarily accepted by what crayon
will accept for you
okay i i lied there's one more question
that i i'm gonna ask right now too
what recommendations do you have for
people who are just learning about cordo
how should they start and what are the
best resources
just do things i mean that's
answer in terms of like that's not fair
but it really is just do things
if you are creating html documents and
if you stick to very basic yaml like
literally like format equals html format
equals pdf
just start doing some of your daily work
there in terms of rather than thinking
about i wrote some dot r files i
generated a csv i take the csv and hand
it off to a colleague or i take it into
excel or i take it into something else
think about what value does quarto bring
to me that ability to mix code that
generates graphics and tables and text
things like lab notebooks or lab reports
or
even for like um within an organization
like generating presentations with code
and graphics not having to manually
rebuild them
or even just normal reports like i got a
lot of value out of that during my phd
using things like our markdown that i
may continue to get value out of with
cordo
if you really are thinking like i just
want to learn and like really learn
deeply quarto.org has the guides
focus again on the subset of topics that
you're trying to learn about maybe it's
presentations and static reports that's
a really great place to start
and there's a lot of powerful things you
can do there
so on the left there's documents and
presentations
if you just focus on those two tabs you
can be very powerful and get a lot of
stuff done
the other part is the authoring section
at the very top
that gives you basically what is all the
quarto specific cool stuff i can do and
again most of that is format agnostic as
opposed to learning just a specific
format so laying tables or graphics or
diagrams or whatever else you can write
out a lot of different things about
what's possible in cordo
the last thing i'll say is come to
isabella velasquez's presentation she'll
be talking about building a blog
maintaining a personal blog as basically
a portfolio is useful for you to learn
things and share that knowledge
as well as
actually use it in practice and then if
you're looking for your next job or
you're just trying to remember what the
heck you did six months ago rather than
digging back through notes you can be
like oh yeah i literally have a blog
post about that so like personally every
time i'm trying to like figure out
okay how do i scrape json data from this
website and bring it in and plot it i
wrote a blog post a year and a half ago
that tells me how to do that i don't
have to store it on my head i can use
the reference material i wrote for
myself
that's great thank you tom and i know
somebody put this tip in the
um slido link as well but also
recommended to check out mine's cordo
tip a day
and i'll show this again
right in the chat window too
i see someone else had just asked they
couldn't attend earlier will the video
remain here yes so the recording one of
the great things about youtube live is
that it will live there immediately
after
the live stream ends as well
um so you can go back there and
review the content and then if you have
follow-up questions i would recommend
again using
this community thread here so we can all
help support each other there and answer
questions as well
tom and i will go through and collect
all of the amazing questions that were
asked today to whether it was on youtube
or slido
group those together and try and put out
a blog post i'm not going to commit the
timeline yet but
we will work on that and getting that
out to you all too
but thank you so much tom for the
workshop today and absolutely sharing
all your
insights with us
thank you for both uh
co-running the slides that was very much
clutch so thank you for rachel for
running through all the slides and for
helping aggregate the questions and
putting this all together
uh shout out to rachel in general so she
does put together the data science
meetup and many other kind of group
community events
uh a great person to follow on linkedin
or twitter just to stay abreast of like
what are all the cool things that the
community is putting together and all
the different events that are happening
i'll let you talk about it but just like
very much appreciate the work you do so
thanks rachel
thank you tom
i put the link here too if people want
to find out about upcoming events i'd
love to see you all there they're
welcome
everybody is welcome at these you don't
have to be
a professional customer of our studio or
feel like you're an expert you could
have just started
everyone is welcome you can listen in
you can join the conversation whatever
you feel comfortable with too
and so
you can view just like upcoming
community events there
but everything is also recorded and
shared to the r studio youtube as well
thank you all for joining us here today
and huge thank you to you tom really
appreciate it
have a great rest of the day everybody